endlich klappte fernseher schon mal
versucht die betreiber einer großen
facebook seite einzuladen ich weiß genau
wie sie risiken falls sie wurde dann
gelöscht von facebook aber die seite die
gibt es noch nur weil ich schwarz bin
was steckt hinter diesem namen wir
werden es erfahren
und ja
390.000 abonnenten oder freunde fans hat
die seite also der absolute wahnsinn wie
haben sie das geschafft das werd ich
fragen und natürlich sind eure fragen
wieder dran am besten schreibt sie in
die kommentare
und dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr
schief gehen ich drücke die daumen dass
er ankommt und wir dürften dann das
geheimnis von nur beim ich schwarz sind
bis dann besser